[Musica]
a ragazzi questa questo momento secolare
della storia con scrive che giorno è
oggi
perché lo guardo sull'orologio è
importante che voi capiate per me quanto
importante questo momento perché è
uscito signore signori repentance che
sarà in si dice così in inglese la
caduta che sarebbe il dlc rialzi di
isaac dopo anni e anni anni anni che
giocano 60 che uscito un dlc che
gigantesco aggiunge talmente tanta roba
che dicono che come se fosse una hit a
più due
io sono emozionato come un bambino sono
sto male sono cambiate le icone a
sinistra ok a mio vedere ragazzi perché
sono curioso della sporco demonio sono
stupido sono curioso nella tre giorni
perché siccome posso re rollare per
vedere se ne esce un nuovo perché non
sono anche oggetti nuovi ci siano
vediamo è forte questo io prendo queste
flyers praticamente ogni tanto spari del
fuoco che fa un male
pazzesco ok quindi la prendono potevano
prenderlo anche se non è un oggetto
nuovo sticazzi isaac versus venga questo
c'era già ragazzi non ho neanche idea di
dove siano i nuovi boss non lo so non ne
ho la più palloni ora più pallida idea
aiuto spara cacche aia ok orco demonio
spara una forest parona focata sparano
infuocata e vabbè ma proprio mentre si
muove vedete quanto cacchio leva al
fuoco rega tantissimo io consiglio
sempre di prendere la roba del fuoco
dallo store o è morto presso un sacco di
vita che caffè c'è la stanza di qualcosa
ma non ho capito cos'è e poi a questo
loro rollo che è una merda cos'è questo
è nuovo e nuovo consolazione
ati da p1 ti dà più uno allo stato più
bassa ok
che strano ti dà più l'ala staff di
balsa va bene va bene la prendo faccio
attenzione a che cosa è questa c'è uno
scherzo con un tombino che cazzo non
ragazzo male non entrò subito da un solo
nelle fogne
ma cos'è i ragazzi oddio santono questi
la fa dando un fastidio come partito
pochissima vita lo stare attento nelle
phone nuovo livello legale foglie e
porca vacca che storia poi c'è una tinta
small rock maroc è molto utile perché ti
aumentando però diminuisce la velocità
molto bene e sto facendo che è
difficilissimo nelle fogne e ragazzi
perché c'è la complice la il riflesso
sotto che ti fotte tifo ma guarda che
brutto ti fotte proprio la vertenza esca
da aprire ho fatto tante chiavi so i
milk che fa schifo e poi c'è
non prendo niente provare il rullar lì
però veramente solo un cuore ragazzi è
un problema può compro assolutamente il
cuore
e poi vorrei comprare questo che è molto
utile ti dà dei minion sono intanto come
faccio a comprarlo aprendo delle cose
dalla donation machine dato sono soldi
che ci ha messo la mia ragazza non è
messo io cosa stracazzo sto vedendo
cos'è sta roba
tra l'altro nel riflesso ci avevano
un'altra faccia sti mostri erano in un
modo normalmente ma di riflesso erano un
altra roba ciò è orribile
non ho trovato un soldo il che è
imbarazzante nostri scolari rollare così
non è 6 milk kemer world but a e tipo de
pin madonna che mal esami che ho fatto
io ho fatto malissimo e tipo de pin che
è un boss normali isaac però non è cioè
tutto strano si muove storto e fa buchi
nel pavimento madonna lega incazzato per
ora cavalca c'è un buco
minchia per quanto ho fatto bene
aiuto aiuto qua ti fotte perché ti crede
i bookie non c'erano allora questo ok
questo un hp up perché no e poi direi di
andare nella stanza di satana l'iter
arming sacrati con cuore per prendere
lila ringers che è praticamente sto
omino che si muove nella stanza e fa
danno per te molto utile di l'arringa se
tutto questo non ho preso la moneta
allora ragazzi siamo soli secchi tutta
roba ma perché tutto un livello nuovo
quindi boss nuovi mobili nuovi tutto
nuovo finissimo in avanti ragazzi porca
vacca c'è un altro secchio bellissimo al
fuoco che si sporca trova affatto un
male cane battiato un secchio in bocca
io prenderei questo che è molto
sottovalutato però a me piace ti fa
vedere semplicemente la vita del the day
mob in giro c'è lo specchio tratto delle
braccia che mi spuntano tutto a posto
c'è la stanza che c'è qualcosa da fare
in sostanza regala se come devo far
saltare il muro da questa parte da
quella parte dove ce lo specchio
dall'altra c'è qualcosa sicuro se trovo
una bomba lo faccio saltare ma non la
troverò mai ho fatto saltare lo specchio
secondo me l'ha portato sfiga adesso
succederà qualcosa di brutto
mi sto gioco nulla è fatto perché sa
dove la figura ci sarà qualcosa di
brutto ma la prendono e capra anzi lo
dico io che minimi
vedete che si vede la vita madonna che
faccio un danno pazzesco stanza di
satana e stanza chiusa con dei legni che
non ho idea di cosa sia ma non importa
ma che non ci fosse entrata prendo
questo ha spinto video è già ottima e
questa stanza di stata vediamo cosa
stracazzo e quella lo voglio subito nome
non solo che cos'è lo prendo formi cosa
fa è un oggetto nuovo di se non so
neanche cosa faccia l'ho preso perché mi
piaceva troppo dove cercarlo
praticamente spaventa un po i nemici
boh vediamo sì è vero sia parco demonio
che male e bene vedere utile cacchio è
utile perché quelli vicino a me prendono
cioè scappano e non è male
non è male è che cagata distanza le odio
le stanze così rega perfetto ottimo 2
danni regalati proprio le ho sempre
odiati sti cosi che spuntano al caso mi
hai preso danno a caso sta buttando un
sacco di cuori lega nel cesso proprio di
saluto
ok judgement che non mi serve oh sì
forse vi serve vediamo quanti soldi ho
questo cos'è che fa
ok praticamente rimpiazzo le con il mie
lacrime sono rimpiazzate da bombe e vi
assicuro che non è male devo solo stare
attento a non farmi a non prendermi
danno da solo perché fanno veramente
danno
ecco il fatto fanno il mio danno per 3 6
12 18 per niente faccio 20 di danno non
è male inoltre o bombe infinite c'è
anche da dire questo però non so perché
devo stare attento a non prender danno
io quella fare in basso a destra che
cacchio è vero che sia mamma bombe sono
che hanno rifatto la cosa i sacchetti
assolutamente abbiamo a andiamo ad est i
cazzi hp up che sta roba qua cos'è cos'è
sta roba lega non ho idea di dove vada a
finire
non so non so niente
ma miniere 26 in barca trottola questa
roba che dai prendo questo no fa schifo
fa schifo è un altro oggetto veramente
inutile
va bene meno male che devo tanto guardo
ok ma quello è un pokémon a posto
queste cose mi fanno una paura tremenda
perché fanno stato cosa
mamma mia
e ora taglia porco del demonio
a questi non devo farli fuori ok possono
più due fuori grigi anziano e mezzo no e
chi non c è nella lava certo li ho fatti
fuori io porti fuori pericolo
porca vacca che anzi difficilissimo tra
l'altro le miniere sono di strà
difficile c'è uno bruttissimo è morto
madonna e sta cosa qua dell'eden della
1000 è veramente la dinamica [ __ ] ma è
difficilissima paralysis ok allora un
sacco di monete di nuovo evans e riesca
a sfruttare qualcosa sacchetto non mi
serve
mi serve una sega sai allora ragazzi
abbiamo un box è il momento di
riprovarci spero non sia mamma kornfeld
è un porca vacca e sulle rotaie
minchia esce alle porte santo iddio è
orribile pure scriva beh a frate calmati
no anzi e saif ei problemi come fai
non capisco una se.ga mi si stanno
incrociando i cervelli che ho ne ho due
non ho mai detto è che male 9 orribile è
difficilissimo è lì
grimsson sbloccato le prince of bones
non solo da siano questa è una merda
lore rollo questa è un'altra ad aprire
gol
meno male possederla e satana quello
anno stata nel quale si fa c'è un'altra
porta quante chiacchiere pure ci sono
adesso satana
ci sono due cuori neri è un orangotango
ok a posto non lo prendo che aumenta un
sacco range questa non è sparita posso
decidere di andare avanti di proseguire
in strade che non non ho mai visto prima
è quella cosa posso dare alla re ancora
una volta ragazzi vediamo qua aprendo il
cose qua ok allora che rollo
vabbè dai poteva andarmi peggio spronata
volta ok 22 fuori per entra porca [ __ ]
minchia che brutta roba entro ma sotto o
due cuori ho speso 30 qua dentro c'è
della roba che non capisco è sicuro lo
conosco l'altro no ogni tanto mi spara
un dente cosa fa questo amidei trasporta
ok prendo questo hai tanto mi spara un
dente che fa cose l'arco demonio
cosa cacchio est opposto è
difficilissimo
c'è gente che spara mausoleo comunque
veramente orribile c a vedersi e tipo
una tomba ok ok veloce veloce veloce
della madonna
certo va bene
nome terribile perfetto questo cosa fa
amica e trasportata parte della stanza
bene i teletrasporti dentro la stanza mi
fanno stranissimo va dai ragazzi uso
decennio the siren
vabbè d'acciaio decennio tifa questo ti
rende immortale come cosa di mario ok
minchia quanta vita c'è la sirena è
morta carino per divenire rimasta lì
cacchio c'era solo un boss che prima
rimane a potevi far saltare in area vt
da una nota forgotten all'abi sing for
your friends il cazzo vuol dire no fermi
vi prego devo vederlo cosa si infuriò
france aumenta il rateo di fuoco dei
minion braga aiuto sono entrato nel
cos'è cioè era 404 questa non cos'è il
bue daì ho trovato nel down ma che sfiga
in monda mannaggia veramente non lo so
ma che sfiga finale mica ho trovato
tears down e del dow ma porco demonio ma
veramente questa sfiga io
porcaccia di una barca in monda ma tolto
un cuore che storia sta facendo è
veramente difficilissimo il mausoleo
ma proprio il disastro adesso pure xeno
perso alcun soft darkness mausoleo
custode darkness è inguardabile già ha
già è difficile per cui non vedo un
cacchio adesso vi si stacca il cervello
a questi che già erano impossibili ok va
bene si capisce una non vedo niente non
si vede nulla maledizione perché non
vedo uno dei due oggetti sempre normale
adesso le hanno forse perché adesso sono
diventati così le 3 gen tu puoi
scegliere tra un oggetto che non vedi
el'altro possibile possibile son
diventate così è cambiata no mi sono
tirato la bomba in faccia e mi stanno
facendo troppo danno
sarà sicuro no che è posto un altra roba
negativa ti ringrazio visto che mi
mancava grazie gentile giusto che
concludiamo almeno qua c'è qualcosa o la
mappa posso vedere e ciò anche un
revolver dopo ok prendo questo che è uno
più uno ogni stanza vediamo se scoprendo
qualcos'altro tipo questa pillola che si
ha un bel ed da un omino al caso
strength posso usare la forza adesso
contro il boss vediamo sarà qua più o
meno è no questi sono perso sono un
miliardo di persistere mi sembra un po
eccessivo come mostro questo comunque
però ok è morto subito una donna
schivato tutto ok siamo arrivati al boss
perfetto siamo la forza contro il boss a
noè mamma perfetto avenoso lo stesso
l'hack è male
trent fortissimo con le mie bombe perché
il triplice aumenta il danno questi tre
piloti ecco perché successo un casino
che non ho neanche capito sto prendendo
danno a caso non capisco neanche chi mi
sta facendo danno non sto capendo niente
di quello che sono morto
non ho capito niente di quello che è
successo sono il successo 8.000 cose ora
i ragazzi questa era isaac di oggi spero
vi sia perché non sono io non so se sono
arrivato lontano no in realtà voleva
fosse la mamma però c'è una difficoltà
extra rispetto a prima
altra roba mi sembra ieri giocava
modalità impossibile ma fighissimo però
fighissimo veramente niente ragazzi
questo momento vi piace il che del
canale e noi ci diamo cos'è il prossimo
video ed ai ragazzi
[Musica]